The day started out actually at an MSNBC live taping,
the taking place a couple blocks away from the Trump rally.
And I kind of went there first because I was very nervous about going to the
Trump rally.
And I went there first because it was more of a comfort zone and just started
chatting with people. And everyone I told, I was like,
I'm thinking about going over the rally. And they were like, don't do it.
They're horrible people.
They're the lowest of the low they're going to harass you.
One woman actually offered me her pepper spray to take with me. And I was like,
no, like I'm going to be fine. It'll be okay.
Can you just go through a little bit of what your political leanings were
beforehand?
Yeah. I've, I've called myself a liberal for like 20 years.
I've been a Democrat since I was 18 years old,
since I was able to register to vote. And frankly,
I never really saw myself leaving the democratic party up until all this started
happening.
So then this all happens and you did the scariest, most evil things.
Someone can do.
You went to a Donald J.
Trump rally.
I did, but we have to back up a little bit cause it,
it didn't actually start there. It started,
it started several months before the Trump rally and I,
when all this was going on, I basically said, you know,
I need to get out of my echo chamber.
I need to get out of my liberal echo chamber because I,
that was the only people I was hearing from not just liberals by progressives
and all this.
And I made this concerted effort to start listening to voices that I thought
I would disagree with.
And my husband who has always been a little bit more conservative than me said,
Carlin, you should listen to Ben Shapiro. You should watch Ben Shapiro.
You'd like him. And I said, no, Victor, I'm not watching Ben Shapiro.
Ben Shapiro is Satan. And then, I mean,
my husband's a pretty smart guy. So eventually I listened to him.
I waited until he was out of the house.
Cause I didn't want to give him that point.
But eventually I listened and you know, it turns out as you know,
Ben Shapiro is not Satan.
He's just like a conservative guy who is also really funny and really smart.
And I just happened to disagree with him on some things.
And from there it was kind of down the down the YouTube rabbit hole where I just
started listening to all these different people and discovering this
conservatives are really not what I thought they were.
It wasn't the perception that I had and you know, living in New Hampshire,
I'm very lucky.
I get to see all the political candidates up close and at one point or another,
I had seen every other political candidate and I thought, you know,
Donald Trump's coming to town. Well, why not?
This is like my big graduation exercise.
Yeah. So, all right. So you go to, well, first off, uh,
tell me a little bit more about the,
those sort of what I described as factory settings that you were a liberal for
20 years. Did it,
did it have any real meaning to you or it was just sort of like where I think a
lot of sort of somewhat apolitical people are where it's sort of like,
Oh Democrats, good Republicans, bad Democrats care about poor people,
Republicans care money, like, you know,
for the person that's not purely political.
It's just sort of the stuff that you kind of get culturally. Uh,
is that basically where you were?
Yeah, I mean kind of, I,
I think I was very active politically when I was younger and then growing up,
I kind of really, after Obama was elected, I kind of shut it all off.
I was like, okay, he's got it. A Democrats in office, it'll be fine. Uh,
but really what I didn't realize is how much Democrats have changed since you
know, between w and what we have now.
And that was really the big shocker for me,
because I became a Democrat because I didn't like,
I didn't like people telling me what to do.
I didn't like people telling me what music I could listen to or trying to
translate their religion or what I could wear or all these things.
And that was what and who to love as well. And that was why I joined originally.
And it didn't occur to me that the democratic party had changed so much from the
thing I joined.
I have heard this story before.
What did you think intuitively about the Republicans?
So you thought they wanted to tell you what music you could listen to and what
video games you could play.
Yeah. I mean, there,
there are horrible evil people that just wanted to control everything I sat and
did was my perception of the Republicans.
Okay. So then Trump comes to New Hampshire and there you are.
There I am.
So the day started out actually at an MSNBC live taping that taking
place a couple blocks away from the Trump rally.
And I kind of went there first because I was very nervous about going to the
Trump rally.
And I went there first because it was more of a comfort zone and just started
chatting with people. And everyone I told, I was like,
I'm thinking about going over the rally. And they were like, don't do it.
They're horrible people.
They're the lowest of the low they're going to harass you.
One woman actually offered me her pepper spray to take with me. And I was like,
no, like, I'm going to be fine. It'll be okay.
And so then I went over to the rally and you know,
you have to get there early because the line is really big and long,
and you're just kind of hanging out and chatting with people and discovered
there, these are not bad people. There was not a Klan uniform in sight.
I didn't meet a Nazi that I am aware of.
There's normal everyday people like veterans and school teachers and small
business owners that just had different ideas about how the country should run.
How shocked were you? I mean, it sounds obvious, right?
The way you're saying it now, it's like, of course it's obvious.
These are regular people. They just happen to have different, uh,
political thoughts than what is sort of more mainstream accepted.
But for you as someone that wasn't part of this bubble,
you get there and you start seeing this, like, were,
were you just like completely blown away?
I think I was more relieved than anything. Honestly, I, I think I was just like,
Oh my God,
these are people that I can have a conversation with because that's something
that is very void in, in the democratic spaces. You have to agree with everyone.
And if you don't agree with them, you're a horrible person.
And so I had for a long time, kept some of my I've always been a centrist.
Really. I'm not,
I've never been terribly far left and I'd always kept my views to myself.
Whereas like these people, I having robust conversations with them even in line.
And I let it slip a couple of times, you know, I'm, I'm a Democrat.
And they were like, Oh my God, welcome you. We're so glad you're here.
And that was very different than what I was expecting.
Yeah. I know the feeling.
So then you go and you hear Trump talk and okay.
There's some agree to disagree stuff. No Nazis is all good.
You decide to write about it. How'd that work?
I did. Well, I almost didn't even write the article to be honest.
Cause I was like, I, this is not my lane. I don't want to talk about politics.
I'm going to get in trouble. I'm going to make someone mad, whatever.
But then I sat down at my desk the next day and I just,
I had to get the ball like out of my system.
And so I went on to medium cause I was like, I don't really use medium.
I hadn't published there in over a year. It was like,
no one's ever going to see this.
And so I wrote the whole article about that surprise. Um,
I wrote it in about 20 minutes and didn't even proofread it before I posted it
and just threw it up and kind of posted it on a couple of like Twitter and
Facebook and all that, and really thought nothing of it after that.
And it got about 200 views the first day.
And then the next day it was like a bomb went off on my life.
Yeah.
So what, okay, so you put it up, you're not really expecting much of anything.
And then, you know, you just can't control the viral nature of these things.
Do you know where the energy behind it started?
Was there a specific person that caught it that set it on fire?
I still haven't been able to figure that out. Honestly,
it started going viral in the morning. Um,
and then I know a whole bunch of people from Fox news tweeted it and Glenn Beck
tweeted it. And at some point in the afternoon, Trump Jr tweeted it.
And that was when it all really started going out of hand. Um, but I mean,
it just I'm, I haven't been able to pinpoint what exactly happened.
Okay. So the thing goes viral.
You're getting support from people that maybe you traditionally wouldn't have
thought would have supported you, the president son. I mean, this is,
this is getting weird. What kind of reaction did you get?
And basically why don't you just lay out a little bit more what you said in the
article? I mean, it's sort of what you've laid out here,
but maybe a little more specifically so that when we talk about the reaction,
it'll be a little better framed.
Yeah. So basically what I said in the article was that, you know,
we need to start taking steps towards one another and to start healing the
political divides. And that,
that I think was the big message I wanted people to take away from it is that
Trump supporters are not bad people. And you know,
hopefully a liberal writing this article, if Trump's supporters think that,
you know, I'm a bad person, they're going to see that, you know, someone,
someone has your back.
And I think that that was what a lot of Trump's supporters really appreciated
about. It was there was this person coming and saying, you know,
you're not a Nazi. I know you're not a Nazi.
We just have different ideas and let's talk about those ideas. And um,
so yeah, and then it was off and running and the response from the,
the Trump supporters or the conservative community,
and those are not always the same thing I've discovered. Um, it's,
it's been amazing, right? They, they really, they,
they embraced me and they was so many of them said, you know, um,
I don't agree with you on a lot of political issues,
but I'm so glad you wrote this.
I'm so glad you're speaking your mind and let's have those conversations.
And a lot of them too, I mean,
I was overwhelmed with the amount of notes I got from people saying, um,
you know, my husband is a Republican Democrat.
I don't know how to make our marriage survive war, you know,
people who have lost family members over this. And I,
so a lot of people really appreciated that. I think they saw in me,
someone that said, you know,
it's possible to get over your Trump derangement syndrome.
And that gave a lot of people hope.
Yeah. And then, you know,
you find yourself on the other side of this and then suddenly all the people
that you might've thought were bad,
guys are being nice to you and agreeing to disagree. And the rest of it, there,
there's a moment there where you have to kind of be like, Oh, was I,
was I really wrong? You have to do a little self reflection. Right?
Yeah. And I've been actually pretty transparent since then that I, you know,
Trump derangement syndrome is a real thing. I had it for years. I,
I regret so many of the things that I've said to people over the last couple of
years now that I've seen the other side of it.
Looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics instead of
nonstop, yelling out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.